parmi les demandes de rendez vous
s'enchaînent pour lui que jacques est à
l'origine de cet engouement soudaine son
récent arrêté municipal qu'il tienne
dans les mêmes cet agriculteur maire
d'une petite commune rurale
il défend l' usage des pesticides les
pesticides ne sont pas si dangereux que
ça s'ils sont bien utilisés à bon
escient et les agriculteurs sont formés
tout au cours de leur vie parce des
certificats pour pouvoir appliquer
correctement les produits au bon moment
à la bonne quantité et uniquement s'il
ya besoin
luc jacquet exploite 125 hectares et se
définit comme une agriculture raisonnée
il dit utiliser de moins en moins de
pesticides mais refuse de se les
interdire son arrêté vise surtout à
dénoncer la grille bashing dont la
profession s'estime victime mais
vraiment c'était pour faire le con tre
contrepoids papara toute la discussion
qui rend monologue contre les étages des
agriculteurs qui font de leur mieux avec
les éléments qu'ils ont pour nourrir
correctement la population française
pour cette militante écologiste l'arrêté
pro pesticides symbolise l'impasse dans
laquelle se trouve le monde agricole
il faut changer de modèle mais aussi
aider et accompagner les agriculteurs ne
comprend pas j'en comprends
l'ironie de ceux de cette demande s'est
arrêtée c'est il faut se remettre en
question autrement c'est vraiment une
question d'argent
il faut que la pac soit diriger
autrement il faut qu'on aide
financièrement tous ces agriculteurs qui
effectivement des emprunts etc à à
pouvoir se convertir vraiment sollicité
la préfecture pour l'heure n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer mais elle devrait
faire annuler l'arrêté municipal prg aux
pesticides